bonsoir monsieur lamarre on se croit
diriez vous que c'est un plan de match
aujourd'hui qui est proposé un plan de
match complet pour restructurer et pour
relancer l'entreprise qui est proposé
par le cirque
oui on a vraiment l'impression qu'on a
un bon plan de match
effectivement c'est un passage obligé
qu'on franchit aujourd'hui parce que
pour nos employés évidemment ce serait
difficile de résister à cette période ci
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que dans la
proposition
il ya la création d'un fonds de 15
millions pour leur venir leur venir en
aide
pendant cette période intérimaire parce
que l'objectif est toujours de les
rappeler
lorsque les activités reprendront mais
seront ils encore au rendez vous ces
employés dans six mois dans 12 mois
quand vous allez lire appelé maintenant
qu'on procède à une fin d'emploi
permanente
évidemment on ne peut pas empêcher les
gens de se trouver d'autres emplois
entre temps on est confiant que la
passion qu'ils ont pour une entreprise
unique au québec à rayonnement
international saura nous aider à les
rapatrier le moment venu et on espère le
plus rapidement possible est-ce que vous
perdez pas quand même une expertise un
talent une partie de l'âme du cirque du
soleil va écouter on essaie de protéger
le plus d'équipés possible au moment où
on a déjà 200 employés clés qu'on a
protégé au siège social est au fur et à
mesure que les spectacles vont
recommencer
on va aller chercher les gens qui nous
sont le plus important dans la
restructuration et la relance du siècle
donc pour bien comprendre d'un côté on
s'occupe de la dette avec les 45% qui
sont proposées aux créanciers bancaires
est ce que ça vient effacer l'ensemble
des 900 ça efface ray l'ensemble des 900
millions de dollars américains de dettes
oui en fait après cette restructuration
la avec le prêt qu'on aura
d'investissement québec et le 50
millions qui a été emprunté récemment à
noah au gros
de prêteurs le cirque recommence fait
ses activités avec une dette de 250
millions et un gland d'affaires très
conservateur pour les deux prochaines
années
ça veut dire quoi un plan conservateur
ça veut dire que comme vous comme nous
tous on ne sait pas à quel moment il y
aura en normalité
donc on ne sait pas à quel moment on
pourra reprendre nos activités de façon
massive donc dans notre plan d'affaires
on a prévu uniquement n'aura pris une
reprise des activités à compter qui
prétend 2021
et est ce que la proche serait plus
conservatrices également est ce que le
site du soleil dans une vision dans deux
trois ans sera un plus petit cirque qui
sera moins étendue on espère avoir un
rayonnement international ou si grand
que nous avions à la fermeture de nos
activités c'est à dire au début de la
crise c'est une entreprise qui a fait
200 millions de profits en 2019 donc on
espère graduellement revenir vers ce
chiffre d'affaires là d'un million un
million contre 2 1 milliards soit 10.2
et arriver à un niveau de profitabilité
important mais on va le faire de façon
ordonnée rich et on va le faire
progressivement pour nous assurer que
les liquidités sont au rendez vous les
liquidités justement on parle de 300
millions de dollars américains donc d'un
côté on ce que de la dette et de l'autre
dans la proposition d'aujourd'hui à 300
millions dont 200 millions qui viennent
investissement québec l'autre 100
millions vié vient d'houllier de qui il
vient de nos actionnaires actuels qui
ont accepté de réinvestir dans
l'entreprise et avec ce 300 millions là
on pense qu'on est en excellente posture
pour faire face à une reprise lente sur
plusieurs mois voire deux ans et on
pense que c'est raisonnable de penser
que d'ici deux ans on aura retrouvé un
niveau de profitabilité acceptable mais
est ce qu'il ya un modèle d'affaires
pour le cirque du soleil à 25 ou 50 % de
capacité d'en haut dans nos
amphithéâtres
il y un modèle d'affaires à 50
100 de nos capacités parce que le point
mort de l'ensemble de nos spectacles et
en 35 à 40 % donc à 50% on peut avoir
une profitabilité de poids maximal bien
sûr mais qui serait relativement
intéressant pour qu'on reprenne
graduellement les activités et encore
une fois on va le faire de façon très
prudent parce que tant et aussi
longtemps qu'on ne sera pas de retour à
la normalité
l'entreprise ne pouvoir reprendre son
rythme de croisière
les gens qui ont acheté des billets et
dont les spectacles sont annulés sont
ils remboursés absolument ils sont
remboursés ou ils ont le choix lors
d'une prochaine visite ou une prochaine
représentation d'utiliser ce billet la
meseta leur choix en rétrospective est
ce qu'il ya des choses que vous auriez
pu faire de me faire mieux est ce qu'il
ya des choses vous vous dites on aurait
de vue avant d'arriver à la crise sans
savoir bien sûr que la crise s'en venait
mais pour rentrer dans une telle crise
est ce qui est des choses que vous
auriez pu faire mieux avant pour mieux
vous préparer à la crise d'accueil 19
je pense que la crise ne pouvait pas
arriver à un pire moment pour nous parce
que après une période de croissance
effrénée
on était rendu c'était notre plan
d'affaires en 2020
on était rendu à optimiser notre
portfolio de spectacles pour arriver à
un niveau de liquidités encore plus
favorable et malheureusement ou dit
lui-même du cycle de ce nouveau plan
d'affaires là on était frappé de plein
fouet par cette crise
et jamais dans ma vie j'aurais cru qu'un
jour le cirque du soleil aurait eu ce 0
revenu depuis maintenant quatre mois
et malheureusement ça risque de se
perpétuer pour encore quelques mois
allez vous rester pdg encore longtemps
monsieur lamarre écoutez moi j'avais dit
que j'étais là pour assurer la survie du
cirque
aujourd'hui je peux dire que la survie
du cirque est assurée maintenant je veux
être là pour accueillir le retour de nos
employés et je resterai le temps qu'il
faut pour assurer la pérennité du cercle
merci beaucoup
daniel lamarre merci bien merci on aura